it is spring break but instead of fun in
the sun later this week some kids across
the valley home recovering from the flu
this is a later than normal flu season
we connect with a local pediatrician to
find out what type of symptoms warrant a
trip to the er as opposed to just a
visit to your doctor
the flu has hit southern nevada we have
a lot of kids coming down prior to
spring break mind you with influenza a
dr kerry weejay sinha of siena
pediatrics in henderson says the strain
is hitting her office hard in just one
day her practice treated 20 kids for the
flu a lot of them are having high fevers
like 102-104
a lot of runny noses cough
very wet cough to sore throats body
aches help us that tips us off to test
and some headaches the flu typically
peaks in december january and february
but we're in mid-april which is the
result of what dr weijie sinha calls
another ripple effect of the pandemic
where certain viruses have been pushed
you know into a kind of different
timeline
and we're all hopeful that it'll reset
at some point while pediatricians are
really good at handling the basics for
flu treatment ear infections sending
kids out for chest x-rays or doing
breathing treatments for kids with
asthma dr weijay singha says rush on
over to the emergency room if your child
exhibits the following having a hard
time breathing
god forbid turning blue
fevers that are not controlled with the
proper doses of motrin and tylenol and
again that's depending on the age of the
child
that would maybe warrant a visit to the
er even in the middle of the night
another thing to be cautious of there
are secondary infections that can start
after you've been diagnosed with the flu
those ear infections we talked about and
pneumonia so she says this is not
something you want to take lightly